hey the new edition of Andrews Chris
crank in vp of two and afternoon UK time
or 13th century p.m. sir he and I'm
Alton Paul buy lunch for here pick any
and all customer with that let's see if
Aaron question Ivan the hangover betta
believe that would you consent your mind
um not much at the moment I've just been
playing with loaders and although
there's there's a temptation to asked
about future releases and things like
that I was wondering if you guys had had
any experience using mark Murphy's
sequel light loader which is designed to
work with databases so I saw that that
he just open source that a new library
of loaders and I had a quick look at it
why would you want to use director
sequel light rather than going through a
punter provider out of interest in most
of my experience whenever using six like
that's basically of putting a content
provider on top a bit one of the things
i'm doing is joining across multiple
tables and so the backend database is a
replica of an external data source and
so they're at separate tables i'm doing
a joint across and rather than having a
content provider for each of those joins
to handle selects and inserts and things
like that I just wanted to have a loader
that ran the query that I wanted to run
and did the join and just basically as a
shortcut to avoid a lot of code you
found it useful yeah you just connect
you've got your own exact sequel
statement that exactly exactly if you
want I said I mean the other thing about
marks framework is he's got some a think
tasks for performing database crud
operations so it takes a lot of the sort
of thinking load off of whether or not
database modifications are being done on
the UI thread
which is quite a cool thing yeah
nobody'd buy some fantastic
fantastically use Excel miles I'll pop
the link to it in the notes if you guys
don't mind so if anyone else is after it
they can go and grab it good idea
they're welcome to a few more live
participants as well Spartan seems to
have disappeared to me I party him maybe
new user got infected titties and but
yeah welcome so alive but it suits book
tars se hello weihai ensure and Edgar
also joining it's like so welcome to
place you guys have any in Harlem and I
had one layer I am implementing a
linkedin connectivity to my app and as a
result in order for me to get access to
the person's a linkedin information I
need to send him to the browser to log
into his account and only then I can
access the information my question is
how do i use a URL call back to return
from the browser after you logged in
back to my app so i think one of the
most common ways of doing this is by
most of these a web will offer will
allow you to tell them at the URL to
redirect to once your fan shape is
finished they specify like a very
specific and URL and then you set up an
intent filter in your application which
handles that URL then you can do it that
way the thing is after you logged in i
get a spatially and token meaning some
kind of way I number but I need to pull
back to use for the rest of the
connectivity the rest of the time is
collected yeah so don't pasta in the
URLs are okay so should I so I should
use web view clip oh you can even better
is it with you but that time it breaks
the whole point if I walk that you can
see the URL and you're really under the
websites to name right and we're
so that's your choice really I don't
think it's a really great solution i'm
on mobile apps at the moment for this
the other thing to do is the probably
account manager with the oauth2 scope as
well didn't you ok Oh ten dollars the
world thank you ok let's you
back now I see if going to chat but I
can't see him then when evers have a
live fishing while we're in the Hangout
now agar and Sean in in the room as well
take those and they feel free to tap out
questions and even in the chat here in
the Hangout if you like or if you're
following along on the live stream then
yeah feel free to ask questions on the
Android developers Fred on google+ am
you all with Matt and fast
okay well in the absence of any live
questions so feel free to speak up in a
bit more questions but as anyone caught
the I guess when it's interesting news
android news this week is the launch of
subscription billing everyone catch that
yet yeah are there any restrictions on
what people can subscribe to so can they
subscribe to say a physical service such
as delivery of toothbrush heads every
couple of months or is it just limited
to digital goods I'd have to check the
docs view sure but I'm pretty sure it's
built on top of them the in-app billing
infrastructure so I'm I'm pretty sure
it'll be the same you know who exits and
restrictions as that and not physical
goods ok cool auto shave club no I was
just thinking amazon do a subscription
service where they will they offer money
off and it would be great to have sort
of an android app where you could pick
out what the stuff was and subscribe to
something or even if there was a digital
magazine a digital version of a magazine
being able to subscribe to the physical
version would be quite cool no I believe
there's still that restriction in our
televisions about not use of physical
goods I don't know where that come from
the y but leave that space I guess a 15
minute refund period is pretty harsh if
you haven't even got the stuff in the
post have you got the moderator of their
neck Apple moderator I was wondering if
we've got any questions from there cuz
having a look at it that looks like a
number of questions there you might want
to have a have a go at if no one else
has got any live questions yeah we just
noticed a machi machi minus
and the egg got last year as well hi
guys you have a question you want to ask
else we're going to jump into the
moderator federal people who are some
questions ahead of time okay we're
jumping for moderator as an interesting
one about how to record what's a
recommended process for communicating
between fragments okay so what is the
best way to implement communication few
fragments nagaland others will let up
and out with two lists pregnant or
choosing a century from right container
which opens with people are going ok ok
so the easiest way to do it so talking
to answer this is by sending have an
interface and you either pass mysteries
by the hosting activity or you can
actually set a listener on one of the
other fragments and register it in the
activities so if you think about it have
fragments AMV and I need to tell you
something the key thing here is that you
don't want to walk and even know
anything about each other there when
people we want to use something like
passing you know using callback
interface by the activity activity in
order to notify each other and I
certainly using a framework that row
matrix example and that offers
impossible I used to retain kind of
thing we could fire off an event and you
will subscribe us happy forever though
that's to keep into it remember really
but you can't really absolutely and
without breaking the behavior
and so yeah particular sample code and
makes its number arts basically one
pregnant that an interface and the
independent will increment it and then
you use the parent activity since yeah I
don't know about anyone else but you're
coming through a little quiet a little
crackly to me Nick and I've the
microphones a bit further away than
normal or something special moderator
yes is this an API I've worked evenings
respondent you were
so last and that is nope we stock
Android love ice cream a method to
display music for any pain it's a widget
locker ooh it went very quiet
targus broadcast and yeah and which
basically do the same job as a as the
stock lock screen but offer a different
variety of functionality so you might
not look into services such as lat but
currently and no there's no way to show
extra options I can throw one across you
that I saw come across on a Twitter feed
yesterday was someone was looking at the
best way to do a three level miss a
nested list that would work on both
tablets and on phones as well there any
recommendations for handed handling that
because I know there's a two level one
that's part of the framework a free
little less of 10 so you kind of way you
can open up and have subsections yeah
I've not really seen any kind of like a
example code for doing that if you think
of any examples in the platform I think
that does that there isn't anything that
I think that was part of what the
question was around because they got the
expandable list adapter which will give
you the two levels it's just sort of if
something needs to go a level beyond
that is it better to try and make it a
single list that expands or is it worth
trying to move users between screens
instead of trying to fit multiple levels
into a single list view yeah I do worry
that that target gets quite complicated
as well when you have free levels within
a single list I would probably start err
towards yet shifting to you know another
list view so clicking on a single item
actually launches you into us into a
subview and if you do need to put them
all together into a single view then you
could just look at the source of the
expandable and expand or list you and
see if you can adapt that source for
your use case but I would start to go to
start to work
about users getting lost when you kind
of have these three different levels
when you get too deep into your now
hierarchy waiting cool thanks cool I
thought this is claiming hello hi how's
it going so we have a question and
developing API to simulate their Google+
a string a hike in the Lisp you yes the
amazing yes that's using a scale
and imagine oh I think he might be miss
it okay
still not hearing whatever not a day yet
okay I pressure a bit of an API to
simulate a lot string effect canales
beer the United net is no mistake your
library to the moment you can easily
build effexor south and agree for you
guys we're getting it and we should EP I
ok oh yeah sitting with earning when you
get you an animation okay wait thank you
I'm guessing egg is a fan what other
people on the viewer live here I think
of the updates the Google+ app like it
don't like it it's been some mixed
comments I quite like it I go I met I
think it looks good I'd still love to be
able to edit posts in it that's one
feature that i'm not i'm really missing
from at the moment but apart from that
yeah i spend more time on it than i do
the mobile website now and also to be
added you love to be able to join their
hand out over the phone not just over a
computer they should there that yeah
something I think regular hangouts you
know I'm at the time i resided in a
horrible odor I'm like really servicing
interesting content and which is good um
I wish you can see a few more comments
maybe but I think it's really visually
beautiful i think they need to do a
little bit of work on the smoothness and
but what I do liver that is how rapidly
they're trading and how they can keep on
bringing you your ex just good so put
the tablet version at some point soon
hopefully as well yeah like they will be
a lovely thinkers on the tablet version
is still something that kind of
irritates me because you want them see
more information and when you put it on
the tab
all it does is just expand the width of
the posts which is a little bit of a
cop-out I on another issue there was the
question about how they're using the up
button yes and it seems to be they've
used it to pull out a side control or as
a side set of levels is that going to be
a recommendation is that against
recommendation or is that just a bit of
artistic freedom the designers have gone
for so it's a pattern which we're seeing
more and more I think kind of it got
popularized by Facebook really with the
button the top left opening a navigation
drawer and I mercurial I I I don't know
it will become an official personal
what's going to happen there but I
actually think it's conceptually very
similar to the expand collapse patent
which you can find on Android design so
this is one of the patterns we've been
touting for when you have multi-pane
layouts where you may have say two
columns in a landscape and layup but
then rotate the phone portrait or tablet
to portray and there just isn't enough
room have to pound slide by side so you
hide it then you can bring it back again
using the up affordance I I think
conceptually what people post is doing
is very very similar so it's almost like
you and you open the application you
you're going to a second level deep like
content view and higher our clear verses
this level above you much like the
dashboard used to be which is just this
navigation pane so I them using the up
to take you back set navigation what I'd
like to see them these probably drop the
up arrow one the navigation pane is
disclosed and probably screen title as
well just to reinforce it feeling like
the navigation pane is this level above
and then when you switch sections
restores your current so that's what I
like so I think yeah it's a natural
extension of the big span collapse
button and I like it cool so what
changes
do you like fee added apart from the
removing the up arrow is there anything
else that you think they should be
looking into implement or any
suggestions you give anyone who's doing
a similar style of app to make their app
to sort of one step better than the
current google +1 sorry is that question
to me yeah yeah it's just basically just
getting from ideas well on where would
you take the app next and what you think
developers could do to improve apps such
as the one for Google+ to make the more
user-friendly apart from the removing
the up arrow went one the navigation
panels expanded is there anything else
that you can see that could be an
opportunity for developers well I'll
sort of saying what I think they do
really nicely I think they do really
kind of a great job of floating up all
the content and that's why you open the
Google+ app right is to go and see your
stream and look at all the great things
that people sharing right so they do a
great job of getting you to that very
very quickly and and there wasn't a nice
job of visually floating at the +1 the
reset button so I think those are the
primary also action they're trying to
get you to do and it seems to be what a
rather than commenting or something else
more longer window so I think they're
really try to promote the very quick
mobile it's kind of snacking pattern so
I want to quickly look at everything in
my feet but I want to go and +1 and
share some stuff and this is a slightly
different than when I'm side a desktop
and I had a bit more time and what
actually want to write a longer response
to them like that so I feel like they've
kind of taken the challenge of mobile
and really kind of done a nice job of
optimizing the use cases rather than
just taking the desktop site and it's
shrinking it down so I think they've
done some really nice stuff there and
I'd love to see them doing more stuff
around tablets like and if they could
you know use of multiple layouts or you
know really really take advantage of all
the extra space I'd love to see that so
I don't know I don't know what the team
were working on what their party's over
hopefully that's on this time any of us
just as well so there were people like
to see or really enjoy google+ app
there's one in the chat from Clemens
it's made a comment about the
readability I've seen that on a couple
of things when you've got a light
background picture and the text put over
the top it's sometimes a bit difficult
to read it yeah that's very true I was
looking I was actually playing with has
anyone checked out Spotify and released
a preview so it's not in the play store
yet but it's on their on their glove on
their website you can go and grab a
preview of what their next step is going
to look like and it's pretty nice and
they've done a lot to really embrace the
ice cream sandwich look and feel and
they do a similar thing with over line
overloads and text on top of some album
art but what they do is they actually
put a very subtle kind of dark gradient
behind it so even though it over a white
text if it's a white album background
it's still very legible so I think that
such a quite the clever solution the
same problem here so and you know what
might seem something like that perhaps
cool we have been immediate assist our
hero seems to them and back yes I I
suffered a massive a massive hang out
failure where I had to I had to do hard
reset the machine by holding the power
button for several seconds like I could
not beg borrow or steal any kind of an
application quitter reset using any of
the standard UI affordances easy a you
know failing failing to have a wall plug
that I could actually yank out I did the
next worst thing I could think of some
there's no question about the animation
and there's a good points just come up
in the chat from Clemens he says you
would love to see an option to disable
the animation I think that's an
interesting point asking that disc
animation should be there to connect the
light and you know mate with me the
experience will feel very fluid and
alive but they shouldn't become like
know too much I think that's what I felt
I feel sometimes playing with and some
HTC phones a sense I've felt like the
animations of great at first but then
after a while I feel like they kind of
start to drag a little bit and get a
little bit hundra and it just feel like
they're kinda lame you can get into the
content I want to get to so they
listened to very minor animations that
make sure they're adding something don't
you them just because you can mmm
there's always about I think there's
always a trade-off between making your
application as friendly as you can to
the sort of the super power users want
to tweak everything and keeping
everything streamlined so it's you know
it's nice to have such things like that
you know to have control panel settings
or preference settings to turn those on
an often well you have to figure out
where you draw the line between control
and just basically where do you draw the
line between control and design like I'm
give the user total control over every
aspect that the app you haven't designed
anything like you're making no decisions
so that's that's the think that's the
balance you're trying to hit its kind of
the case for sensible defaults and
whether the sensible defaults or what we
did the biggest sort of wow factor when
the user picks a device up or whether
it's something that they'll be able to
use long-term yeah it's also bearing in
mind as developers on you know perhaps
it's similar to all of our use we're
quite happy with like a massive screen
of options right with to us that feels
powerful like we're in control but let's
take a second to think you're up to your
users feel the same thing I think that
presenting a massive screening of
options can be very daunting to
certainly especially to new users so
perhaps like hi those under like an
advanced level if you must or you know
better yet would be no option at all and
do some sensible people it's unfortunate
about the the German lock I've just seen
a comment from Harley he does you
android UI patterns and he'd love to
join us but virtually in Germany so he'd
block to the neighbors so hopefully
he'll play some of these comments up
later and we can see what he thinks
because they come across some really
nice patent in apps I just seen him now
ya hear on the G first place looking for
joining or a Yanni alright so my Alex
amazing talk about if
curious to know what I missed in my
extended absence were there any any
questions from the people who are live
on the Hangout right now as we haven't
had a chance to answer quest as good
question yet yeah I've got a question
here regarding pin hitter list views I
know it's a delve into source code and
it's been commented that you know there
might be a potential for her to actually
surface that as a proper API but I was
wondering if you know somehow it could
be bundled in in one of the support
packages because I'm looking at the
Android designed for this fuse and they
specifically say they use proper headers
and the heavens so answer design but
trying to implement it for hollow is
really really difficult and the actual
calls and mucking around the source code
it's quite difficult when you're trying
to scroll up and down the list yeah that
is a good idea so have you looked at the
contacts application so contacts this
day yeah I have but the thing is it's
running off I think it's oh well I think
the cursor adapter and I'm trying to use
it just based on a simple array adapter
but you know I spent quite a while
trying to adapt it and I was like nah
this is just too hot so I just end up
doing it static you know I hate the list
but ideally you'd want to have something
that Scrolls along and saying patent
that the contact application has yeah so
there is a library out there that supply
be up some source code I member I've
done this before i just googled a rapper
doesn't remember who it was he published
it but um seems my mac or not if i flip
effect and trying to fit the source code
as well as meantime I think it's no work
when is definitely some source code out
there fittings pinned header it wasn't
coming in my right
Matt ganda the chat is saying he thinks
maybe Marc Murphy has something like
this so solo killings in his sample
applications right okay so I had a quiz
I want to ask about the the Galaxy Nexus
is there a way to know which a frequency
out of the five users to connect to the
tower probably not because I know for
example on the galaxy s so you can dive
in let's take a special number on the
diet and shows you the information hmm
is about the aus feels like just try to
get to know it's a galaxy s2 are running
ginger blood this is actually the first
time I've ever heard anyone even suggest
that I've no tried to do this I don't
know offhand you looked in to the
connectivity manager and seeing what
that exposes for you and the best thing
that I add you know that I tried is to
dive in the fall 636 number inside the
die pad and it showed some information
but runs that information yeah there's
you get a network think if you imagine
get your network inside objects I love
interest worried it what do you use
information forks there may be a better
way to achieve the same car yeah well
it's something to test with my new
career that excuse is still frequent
season for some reason while for some
was it sometimes data that works amazing
like nine megabits per second and other
x equals x 0.5 that I think it's a
frequency problem
is that in the same location or is that
moving around between places because it
should just be coverage issue and now
it's on the same location because I'm it
seems to be on a tipping point that they
change frequencies so on the galaxy s2 I
see the two frequencies button the
Galaxy Nexus and I can see it is your
phone broken rooted because you know you
could just be unknown ETA versus UMTS
and if it looks between those two and i
get the same problem as well but i'm
running cyanogenmod so i can tell when
i'm on hsdpa and it's significantly
faster when you're on our hsdpa network
but it's on the same frequency low i
well I know my can I use this tool
that's why I'm asking because if it
feels to me one little don't be relevant
fair enough yet they've actually trying
to write little app to to log or show
what frequency your honor easy you can
find diagnosis yeah till they still
there it's like a nap or way you know we
do something on the phone dialing some
special code and it will show you it
magically but I guess you don't have
that on the Galaxy Nexus I and not I
know of like I know it's eat up in the
source code for the toilet and you can
see these special photos that you can
enter you know like / the hash infohash
dashte and so on the next threat the
threat for those in the style of source
code and i'll show you which you can
test the screens and I which leads to
and you can check those out and see if
they obviously have to get your Z get
towards the information 15 finish
everything can you put a poster in from
the tip so i can log book we're just
looking looking the dialer and
application
I'll grab a link of the github mirror if
you want neck yeah W listen thank you is
very much an interesting question on the
sidebar chat here Michael handler wants
to know can you call garbage collection
on an activity after finished so it will
be removed a stack no I don't think I
can I don't think you can call anything
after finished I think that starting
with Gingerbread are garbage collection
got so good we stopped recommending that
you call garbage collect at all you just
you should just write your things go out
of scope and let the system take care of
it we have any other any other questions
from the people in the Hangout it's kind
of one that I'm not sure you'll be able
to comment on but it's there's a lot of
talk about HTC tweaking the multitasking
on the One X so that it only allows very
few applications to run at any one time
do you know if that's something that's
likely to be adopted more widely or is
that a recommendation that's been
supported by google or is out something
HTC you've just going off the ranch and
done themselves I don't even know if
there's a ranch to be on I mean it's you
know it's an oem rom and it's an
audience ition isn't it so I think it's
just up to them and as I think the
market is going to either reward them or
punish them accordingly true true I've
seen a lot of people who aren't happy
about it but I suppose if users are
happy that's the main thing so yeah I
just remember the problem was with that
listening thing I did roll my own
implementation but i have a question is
the background for holo white as in the
emulator or is it a gradient as in the
device because i noticed they're both
different
under default think the thief oh is it
do Nixon spark everything to lost you
guys yeah yeah so I I think the I think
the default backbone is just a solid
color isn't it it's it's either dark or
light depending on whether you use holo
light or holo dark yeah that's what I
thought the emulator seems to be either
just white or black but on some devices
there is a gradient or something like
that so I'm kind of puzzled what's that
why is it not the same from the emulator
through device well this shouldn't be
messing with hollow I mean there there
is a device default theme which the OEM
you can customize to their heart's
content but I think your hollow sleep
your hollow I'm going to have a check in
the AOSP source code because it might
just be that it is supposed to be a
gradient but the emulator doesn't render
the gradient in order to get a
performance-based hmm that could be
right you know I know it's just like
fire official up and talk to make the
idol hmm
looking API demos right now trying to
see if there if I can see if there's
anything like a gradient here yes this
kind of look later at the bottom though
isn't it well we're figuring that out uh
any other questions from the from hang
out yeah Clement says you've seen the
gradient tube yeah I thought that was
the default in ICS so how is that how is
that working with your pen oh it's just
the the this source for Mike Murphy
stuff and some of the other
implementations of the pin headers use
solid colors works perfectly fine when
you're at the top of the list but once
you start going down bottom of list if
there's a gradient you know that you're
looking at her I headed you're not
looking at a sort of a transparent
hollow element so when I tested it out
on the area that I was like sweet this
worked you know it looks great and I put
it on the phone I was like oh what's
going on here the gradient so that's the
main problem and I try doing the
transparent backgrounds for the pin
headers but then if you have a listview
behind those hitters then you start
seeing the text behind the other text
and it just gets very confusing did you
set background color on the list view
itself no I don't think I was a
transparent ListView so the I think with
all this use I transparent I think
if I can it just looking at the contact
yeah like thank you yeah no I just can't
really hear the audio was with soft on
it was your end all right i was just
saying they basically set so they know
my background is that you can quickly do
things in our that to avoid this great
danger uh oh no i actually didn't run
maybe maybe there is the case i actually
didn't notice i thought the contacts app
stool actually has the gradient behind a
bit i'll go have a look and see i could
just be mistaken with that I would like
I never noticed it before but I'm
looking at some of the API demos and
then you look at it I don't know if you
can tell but it kind of looks kind of
looks later at the bottom then at the
top don't you think yeah pianist stomach
I I honestly never noticed before this
is this is because i think in code not
pictures although all that visuals that
only distraction they fit i want to i
want to see the world just like the
matrix it's just the little screens of
characters floating across my
consciousness blonde brunette redhead
sushi
if you had a question from the moderator
yet let's look yeah we retain a couple
of much moderator we went for one on
fragmentation okay we also talked about
upswing equal what if you live
participant is a micro is you can have
an election cycle this is
question about the animation issue
question is in moderation no it's not
okay will feel free to talk it out let's
see if you talk about the Google Apps
question where can I find documentation
white URL parameters google maps for
android supports that's an interesting
question because it's not really an
Android programming question so i don't
really have to take it but i'll take it
anyway and i think the answer is it's
not documented there's this interesting
link at quarry screen gotta work and
some of those some of those oral
arguments believe that the offer of
actually work if you type them into the
search window yeah good maps on android
though i think there's some opportunity
here for some enterprising similar to go
in and try those out and see which one
which of those parameters work in which
ones don't go anything and there is some
documentation of work and i'm just going
to developer.android.com go to the death
guide and then write down the bottom
there in the appendix is a section
called intense lyst google apps i post a
link to it here in the chat so this this
table here it is actually possible what
brand is your particular matter and also
distribute LG how to part a lot long
pair and we level or very informative
for those and
no point of like very scary you and put
on all maps rather than I think well
it's the same thang
that's cool
to Matt artists in the chat is complete
I don't know this list is being that if
I think sin for a while so I don't know
if any components a bit like the nuts
application which handles it
significantly surprise Bay more
functionality that we simply declared
I'm not saying things that might app
takes more functionality I've seen it
handle things like at the navigation
format for Jean basically have a web URL
navigation type of RL Matt people but
happily pop up and do that but I would
say that's not a document as though it
made great so Michael is painstakingly
club that his question that when we go
back to that we asked he's noticed that
gallaugher through and there's not
always move an object of abominations
enterprise and is that fixed and free
from oh I made a fix for free people oh
I just and which initially we picked up
on it yeah so this picks a deeper issue
that the really plenty by an animation
frame blog and basically moved around
the rendering of things on screen that
didn't actually move the underlying
object there for example if your
animated a button to the right by 50
tips then it would appear to be on the
right on the screen but its actual
applicable bounds we're still in the
same place so yeah you're very correct
that the new animation system number
three Fontenot the Android or animation
package does fix that is actually move
objects around rather than just whether
integral on the screen so it's not
something fixed is a completely
different animation package there so
yeah you talk about what's the best way
to approach this in a difference then
and so there's some things out there
like nine or androids which is a great
framework for the answer right to the
three-point no api and have it backwards
compatible but i don't believe that
fixes this object i think if it is
running on the old animation system it
won't actually move the object bounds so
I think you can i'm probably going to
have to write different different code
for pre and post free porno
then last any experience this message ad
group sounds like a good opportunity to
go multi APK and/or have a deluxe tablet
and honeycomb and aura and Ice Cream
Sandwich edition jean-michel handler
likes deluxe editions okay step three
profit is that what you're saying what
what's step two again magic happens okay
just feel joined by Larry over honey hi
there yeah welcome to the Hangout do you
have any questions of Android
development yeah I am one question and
it's about the list view inside if
fragment Lewis view okay you know I had
I'm program this missile with a white
background well actually I assume it was
default as a white background and but
then I tested out on the gingerbread and
froyo devices as well as on tablets so
we leave the honeycomb and always was
okay all was ok and I was crawling it
was ok and then I got ICS upgrade and
then I tested out the this this activity
meet with the the fragment list view and
actually and sometimes scrolling the the
dispute that some rows of this list
video where were as scrolling neverender
de is a breakup background so I wanted
to ask I sbisa putting a white
background
and with a drawable white background so
actually now when I scroll the newest
video it's all ok but I wanted to ask as
a default maybe if this is happening
because the ND filter the big round of
the views are and don't have a white
background do they have a black the
grounds of what what can position yeah
this sort of gets to what we were
talking about a few minutes ago um I
kind of suspect that the default maybe a
transparent background yeah so I I think
that having a you know even even
assigning a style that's conditional on
be 11 so that you get a list background
style that only kicks in when you are on
Honeycomb or higher would be a fine
solution and if you want your you know
if you want your list views to look the
same on all the different versions
because you have you know you have a
user interface vision and you want to
keep a consistent aesthetic that's an
excellent design choices that's what we
want to do it ok good
well let's see what the moderator has in
store for us hmm here's a question from
Gabriel ittner in Berlin who has a lot
of challenging questions that I don't
know the answers to does I have a widget
containing a list view in the remote
views service I use a cursor loader to
query data from a content provider the
cursor loader automatically re queries
when I call change notify on the Ori
should I still implement a Content
observer and then he is referencing one
of our sample apps says app widgets can
be stick around a long time without
getting reloaded refreshing the content
changed with the cursor loader does work
short term but he wants to know will it
work long term as well or does there
come a point when the cursor loader
stops me querying and I will if I recall
correctly he's citing our our weather
widget that's in our samples and my
hands are to him in the moderator is I
don't know so it may be somebody in the
and the Hangout has some opinion on this
when you are powering a widget with a
list view with a content provider should
you also do a Content observer in the
widget a lot like that they my gut
feeling says no that that's what the
load I should do for you that was sort
of my feeling too and at similar to
another question that I gave him just
because just because it's in one of our
sample codes does not necessarily mean
that it's the end-all be-all of best
practices we try to encapsulate some
best practices in our samples but we're
not perfect and sometimes if a sample
may be oriented towards trying to
illustrate best practices in one aspect
of the API and they cuts the quarters on
the other ones well thank you like
loaders comes along in the sample
doesn't get updated for it that too
yeah my I'm thinking in particular of
some samples that have a lot of static
internal classes where you have an
activity then you have 17 classes inside
the activity it makes for a nice well
contain sample but it's perhaps not
you're not exactly the poster child for
factoring the the next question in the
moderator is also by Gabriel one to know
in the wiktionary sample says it uses a
service to prevent an a in our
application that were spawning but since
it's a simple service and runs in the UI
thread how does it help to prevent an
eight an hour just to put it in service
shouldn't the service run its own thread
and I think the answer to that is yes
the service should still spin off its
own thread in order to prevent the ANR
and I wanted to take this opportunity
also to say that a very convenient way
to make a service run and its own thread
is to to create an intent service which
does that automatically it's a newer
form of service and it's very convenient
than the syntax to create an intent
service is very simple so I recommend
them more questions in that chat if
there any questions in the in the stream
I haven't been following it I've been
perfection that it was the first place
and I'll for a quick question about
there my boss wanted me to ask is it
possible to fields I and other fighter
chips
I've never heard that it is I think it's
a completely different radio technology
in so they have to use like a decay or
something like that so a different
external device and then plots are the
data to the Android device so that might
do i would but investigate if you can
use NFC because there there's a lot more
support built into the platform that but
it's not an option you have to work with
our i did this you know really some
infrastructure in the field or something
then yeah something like an the ADK with
the weights gay ok it's in depends on
the client not on assets their
requirement a plan sir well i'm a big
believer in here telling the customer
they're not always right on that they
should they should make requirements
that are easier for you as a developer
to implement that goes down really well
well it's their choice so Jeff that's
good i'm joking actually early in my
career I did sort of take a stand and
tell the customer that the software
package they mandated that we should use
wasn't the best suited to the task and I
proposed I proposed something I thought
was a bit more powerful and could do
what they wanted and and they went with
my choice and it turned out to be a good
decision in the long run but if I had to
go back and do it again I'd probably
also push back on their design saying
that maybe they should have designed
something that was a little more
implementation friendly as well when I
suggested a messy but the problem is
it's already a final hablar por that's
another change the final hardware for
the disappearance is a bit difficult
it's not something that its production
so I'd be out there way yeah it's a lot
harder to a lot harder to push back on
design requirements before you start
getting gray hairs like I've got it
gives me a little more gravitas we just
got a hello from no um in the sidebar
chad is no I'm also in the Hangout did
you want to ask us a question you're
gonna win the dark there ones writing a
little mms
little help hmm why it's pretty uh
that's pretty open-ended isn't it I
think yeah I think we need a slightly
more targeted question than that no I'm
says the camera isn't working have you
seen the have you seen the developer
training article about using the camera
it's a I'll be the first to admit it's
not perfect since I wrote it but it
should at least get the fundamentals out
this thing different slaps whoosh whap
whap as in what we used before
telephones head internet hmm Wow how
would i parse the mms message yeah I
don't know sorry I don't know anything
about that so I don't know probably say
look at the NS app in the android open
source tree as your first protocol and
see if there's any pointers you can go
on it from that excellent suggestion now
I always refer back to the AOSP you're
you're a resource of final resort I
imagine issues what I find is quite hard
at the easiest way to navigate a project
i don't really know about it's just open
up the manifest file and see what or
getting two points it to the app that
way that's what i like to do and find
out you know you know what's that can
you see on screen so you can really map
your experience from using the app to
the codes that's why i like to do it
new leg jeans we can't build you can't
be of the Android source on windows I'm
just reading no arms follow up and
finally I've managed to dig out the holo
theme definition the background should
be solid black or solid white for hollow
light gradients must be something that
somebody's tweaked with okay is that
right yeah I suppose it's one of those
things that's not leave itll if it's
almost unnoticeable to users well ah i
see that we're about out of time and I
would like to thank you all for coming I
need to clear out of here I'm in a
double booked resource but if the rest
of you want to keep on chatting feel
free to carry on but I need to go now so
fais pas cake let's do it thanks for
joining everyone bye to my way